me just say a couple of comments okay
all right so we go uh the first thing
I'd like to Sean is um don't use this
hook that hook of her thumb which is
kind of perpendicular let's exaggerate
it open the rest of the grip do you see
and it's right
there don't use that ledge on that
ledge don't go like this
okay my advice would be the opposite
open L gong and feel more of the
hand feel F their hand okay even don't
start using this hook but you touch
everything okay so come in she touches
and she's there I want to reach out and
touch her back do you see how I did that
okay that would be better so I'll show
you the
difference go
and I'm in here and I'm more getting out
of the way of you if you pay attention
there's a little bit okay oh we go
again okay and now there's more contact
area and so there's
more uh friction which is adhesion
resistance to you pulling backwards you
see okay and so if she has resistance to
pulling moppers then I have a very good
structural to bringing her forward okay
so reach up and fill whatever they don't
okay you see that okay and
then it's not that she's still trying to
do spinal displacement right cuz we
would be hanging out here in the drill
but now I move the drill by Just sh
simply shifting my weight without
changing the pressure okay
so maybe there was some
confusion is that you were only supposed
to feel my
feet and
not
push got it okay so let's make sure the
UK feels my feet there we are okay and
you you have to ground on the front foot
in this case because we're going to move
to the back foot so she's she's actually
feeling my front foot and now I keep
this i f the space face and I just move
the whole engine okay got it okay that's
the drill let me feel
some come
back so here's what I felt you're there
okay and you just touch my feet just
touch my feet don't come don't don't
confuse this with touching my feet
okay there they are right there I'll
show you you see okay you touch my feet
and what I mean when I say I show you is
that you see if I if at the moment that
we're there then as I move towards you
it would it moves your Center you see
okay so you're
there there we are oh don't fluctuate it
oh
oh look how I'm going towards you cuz
you keep going off do you see okay there
we are all right and then here's what I
felt you see how you didn't come with me
okay so uh I keep the pressure that I
feel here and then that pressure that
pressure moves and you're you're going
to feel that because you're not spinally
displacing okay and I'm trying to move
it the pressure at the hands will
slightly increased do do you get that so
watch as I I'm here Mark that as zero
feel more more more okay more more if we
go now that's me moving towards my rear
now you start to move towards your rear
look you got more you see that more more
pressure at the hands cuz they it's
trying to come apart okay so it's not
me getting getting out of the
way okay it's me
holding and
moving that
thing okay and me moving that
thing okay and you notice
that when I went with you when I went
with you you had to take a step because
even in the in the range of motion of
the boat rowing
exercise if your feet stay still as they
are in this drill your line of gravity
will fall outside your base of support
and you would have to step in order to
not hit your face okay so when you guys
did
it you're
like this and you're never going to step
or you feel that and you go like
here so my my arms came forward do you
see so I feel it and you'll see my feet
are fairly close together I'll make them
fairly close together but it it'll be
enough there's the increase in pressure
increase in pressure increase in
pressure you see and because the center
moves right
away you're going to have to take that
step okay all right so I'm not getting
out of the way the pressure should
actually increase okay uh but if you go
too y right right and then I'm out there
was a slip did you feel the slip okay
right no I can't do that but you when
you're feeling you went to Yin which is
I'm going to get out of the way let's
not get out of the way okay all right
try
okay so we go okay and uh I want you to
to feel it the things that I've said so
far I want you to feel it okay
so uh I'm not going to try to use those
hooks you feel that your thumb is right
in the Palm is where the Palm is where I
am the palm right there okay I can't
make any more contact with that cuz the
way you grip with your T-Rex arms but
it's fine for I don't care okay all
right uh and now if I uh go
light you see how it goes off and then
there's the slippage you just just ever
so slight but when you go fast it's gone
okay all right so there we are
okay there more I feel your feet I don't
think you feel my feet there you go okay
all right and then here's going to be
and again once you feel my feet I don't
want you to finally displace you're just
hanging out there okay all right and
then I don't want to go so hard cuz this
might not seem like I'm slipping but
energy does go out into your arms do you
see that so right when we're here again
just feel my
feet without the final displacement
there we go okay um and now what I'm
going to do if I do all this right I
don't move your
arms I don't move your
shoulders do you see I feel what we're
doing my hands pretty relaxed okay and I
don't allow those that joint
articulation to happen okay
such that for
example if you uh try to extend your
hands which would require you to extend
your elbows you see you can't and if you
try to uh roll your shoulders back
you're going to go like this you got it
okay you roll your shoulders back oh
crap you see okay now what we want and
so now when I get into this position
then the center is going to keep moving
right away
right away you see okay not not any
slack up in the arms up in the shoulders
you see how our shoulders go first okay
all that I'm I'm starting to move this
so another way we might as well go there
is we'll go this
way
okay so again
different
shoulder elbow
okay
oh here again try to pull your hand back
and the elbow can't try to push it
forward and the elbow can't can you see
try to move it out try to move your arm
out and you can't okay and so once I
have here that's that's what I move the
I move the center the center comes up
okay forcing them in this case he you
better put your line of gravity you
better put your Bas of support back
underneath so I'm here feel that and I
move
that okay you kind of course go the
other way does it
matter okay let's try that
one um okay and I I again the external
you do use it we use it okay um but
that's not in this drill we're not doing
it in this drill okay so for for
example in in our kazushi patterns I do
want your spine to tilt okay and uh that
means that I'm going to lean you one way
or another I'm going to lean you okay um
and that does generate a line of gravity
moving outside the base of support but
unlike bad iido or or even you know bad
any of the bad grappling Arts
I have to
also make your tonden your Center this
let's just not the tonden your
center of gravity I have to also have it
traversed through the satal plane in in
Iko that's why you have a a spiraling uh
rotating of the UK's body across the mat
okay so um in this drill we're just
working on that that the center is
traversing through the sagittal plane
and not tilting you and then eventually
because you had to move the center
traversed okay so uh not
intentional in the last
filming um but you can go back and look
at
Virginia's
um left
shoulder and you not going to see that
it's dropping and lowering in relation
to the right one and and then eventually
they step and regain their base um since
it wasn't intentional to show uh we
found that if you look at this shoulder
near the camera uh you would see that it
did not go up which would be indicative
of this shoulder going down okay so in
other words I'm not here she touches I'm
not trying to go like this and then she
fell out okay I'm not trying to do that
in this drill uh I make those
connections okay and then I'm I'm moving
this thing the center here so if you
watch her
shoulders uh I'm not going to make them
go
here okay they're just moving
across feel my feet I see what you're
saying Virginia come on feel my
feet there we go
okay then I move that
across feel my feet feel my feet feel my
feet feel my feet your job feel my feet
feel
I think you're stuck on the low pressure
hi so you do that a lot you're my
little autistic literalist here okay so
yes but I feel your feet so I'll show
you let's show you there's your
feet you see not
here not touching
feet there's your feet
right
there you
see life pressure yes no feet just
touching here I got to feel the feet
there it
is okay so this drill feel the feet
that's very light feel do you feel my
feet yes okay cool there now you went
off again feel my
feet don't do anything and you it's fine
cuz we're not throwing you okay we're
not going to throw you just feel my
feet don't do anything feel the feet
don't do anything feel the feet don't do
anything feel the
feet don't do anything let what's
happening
happen
good
e
e e
dip
it
okay here feel my
feet there we go okay and then from this
I just move my body
my again we can watch this shoulder not
you that camera person feel my
feet te your
C feel my
feet
okay okay go the other way
okay TR it okay uh some other stuff came
up though
right cuz we see this in the in the
ukemi right like whoa and then you you
pull out of the stuff right okay so this
is
as gentle as it's going to ever get okay
so I feel the
feet that's all I do is
UK okay you could say it's not about
being hard and
aggressive I don't do
anything and then I want you to turn
slowly and I don't do
anything I don't even have to predict
which way you're taking me I just keep
feeling the
feet okay and we'll do that
again
okay wait till and so again what I'm
saying
is there's your feet you
see okay
not about pressure not not not about
this tension
okay and then I just let
happen but it's going to
happen okay and I'll show you what I did
I don't know where you were looking or
my eyes were shut okay but this is all I
did does it look violent no okay but
emotionally it's probably terrifying
because you're not in control of it got
it but this is the time to use that
because it's not there's no irreversible
consequences of not being in control so
right now your ego tripartite mind has
been raised and re reared and supported
and
paid to believe you better control as
much as you can or bad shit's
going to happen okay and
so Decades of that training and now
you're being
asked hey instead of trying to control
things why don't you instead work on the
need to be in
control CU if you lose that need the
fear goes goes away and then I don't
need that okay then I'm not terrified
when I'm not in
control okay so this is a time in the
dojo like a kind of physios
psychological
therapy this is all you're
doing that was it but you're going to
let it happen just let it happen okay
got it so you come over here
and you're just going to gently push me
with one
fingertip okay till that till I have to
do
that yep just keep
going and then I have to okay let's
see and don't make it happen because
that's the kind of control do you
understand okay that and that's the
tricky
thing don't do anything be dead be dead
don't do iido don't do anything you're
just standing there okay okay don't push
into me
okay you locked up don't don't organize
your body for budo just stand
normal don't do anything don't do
anything you're organizing it again
and what I mean to that is you given
structure to your body I don't want
structure I don't want structure
okay don't structure up cuz that's a
fear
response there you go we'll do it again
it's not bad it's worse than the other
one though to tell you the truth
okay don't do anything just
except don't do
anything okay don't do anything don't do
anything except don't be ahead of it
that's controlling it hi let it move you
that's it let it move
you much
better great
okay
um then back into the drill but that's
very important because that has a lot to
do with whether you can do these
energetics or not that fear is so woven
into our experience and our identity
that it generates the microt tensions
and the
contestations under which I can't
develop these internal skills okay all
right but back to the drill uh when I
was pushing her like that that's an
external push and and if you paid
attention uh you would see that her
shoulder
lean okay you can go back and see that
that's what happens when you do the
external push okay eventually it'll pull
on the center and yes the center
traverses across the M but what happens
in real
life is and she pushes my she pushes my
shoulder before my Center gets
pulled in real life life people go like
this do you see and then your out
of lock
okay all right